[Music]
on a research boat usually it's the new
guy who gets the dirtiest job this time
is no exception I'm Wes Larsen a
wildlife biologist and lover of the
outdoors for as long as I can remember
I'm traveling the country to find the
next generation of conservationists the
people on the front lines of the fight
to understand our planet and protect the
animals we share it with we've got a
pretty big hermit crab today I'm headed
to Sarasota on the Gulf Coast of Florida
it's home to a beautiful a little
understood animal the spotted eagle ray
I'm joining up with the research team
from Florida Atlantic University and
Mote Marine Lab there's some of the
first scientists in the world to study
this animal in depth so Brianna what are
we doing today so today we're gonna
attempt to visually spot some spotted
eagle rays bring it on board take a
bunch of samples and then we'll release
it back into the wild
I'm Way excited Brianna deGruy is a
master student at FAU she's been
obsessed with race ever since she was 11
years old and she's leading the field
research today spotted Eagle razor
pretty understudied we really don't know
a lot about them right yeah there's not
a whole lot of information about just
even their basic biology or ecology so
what do they mean for the environment
how are they affecting the environment
how many of them are out there and from
an environmental
they're really important to keeping the
ecosystem in balance so it's really
important that we understand basic
questions about them which is what we're
trying to do here
[Music]
grow up on the spotting tower point the
view up here you can definitely see into
the water along better than you can down
there
they stand out pretty good we're gonna
go over a grass bed right now infinity
to hide the grass what we're looking for
is there a large enough to surgically
implant a tracker and it takes an
experienced eye to spot one right there
yeah I believe so that's him that's him
that's an eagle rated you ready
catching array is a complicated maneuver
we have to completely encircle it with
the net or the ray will escape and
you've got to be quick about it
the waters really choppy in these and
maneuvers that they do at the photo
really dress it once we've got it
surrounded we need to bring in the rave
I hand he's in the middle he's going to
the north
[Music]
this ray turns out to be tiny just a
juvenile my job is to hold it in place
while the team does their work despite
its size it's not easy as soon as we
flip them over you can really see how
much she's calm down that's the state
that they go into called tonic
immobility it's kind of like the Rays
hypnotize a lot easier to work with any
money putting is on its belly we get
there are quite a bit bigger than this
right yes we get to be about seven feet
I want to separate this ray is too small
to surgically implant a tracking device
so once we've gathered what data we can
it's time to let him go and while the
spotters keep an eye out for a big ray
we take a break from the hunt when you
begin researching an animal one of the
most fundamental things to understand is
its eating habits and to figure out the
eagle rays the team has come up with a
creative solution
[Music]
Breana this is kind of what we're
looking for exactly this is a gastropod
or for the layman we take back the
snails and clams to the lab where the
team has two wild rays in a holding tank
we're gonna put some free items into the
water and we're going to record the
sounds that they're making while they're
crunching down on the hard shelled prey
items and we're trying to decipher if
these different prey items are making
different signature sounds by tracking
the sounds that different shells make
when the race crunch them the team
believes that they can decipher the
Eagle race diet that's big just crunched
it there exactly yep but the hope is to
put these listening stations out into
the environment and we can know exactly
what they're eating when they're eating
it and how much they're consuming as the
captive raise crunch away we get word
that another has been spotted offshore
that's bigger so it's time to head back
into the Gulf for one last attempt to
catch a big one we just got word there's
another spotted eagle ray got double the
size one selfie concurrently
so we're on our way to go relocate it
and hopefully we'll get another right
hand for it ready it's pretty clear when
the team grabs the other net that this
is a much bigger array this raised over
five feet wide from wingtip to wingtip
plenty big enough for the surgery
Brianna's hoping to do my job
holding the Ray upside down and
perfectly still while she implants the
tracking tag so preparing all of our
surgeries supplies to do an internal
acoustic surgery it's a really quick
procedure we're an internal tag is
implanted into their belly area and it
allows us to follow their movements as
they travel up and down the coastline
sharks and rays don't feel pain the same
way humans do and with the Ray on its
back it stays calm and relaxed
throughout the procedure
yeah that's quick
the surgery is over in just a few
minutes this tag will allow the team to
track her for years to come
giving them a detailed picture of where
eagle rays live and how far they travel
putting us one step closer to
understanding this beautiful animal I
come from a mammal background and
working with mammals there's kind of
this natural connection that you have
with them and I didn't really expect to
have that sort of connection with these
rays but when we pulled them up onto the
boat I felt this intelligence coming out
of them they're very personable animal
yeah that's a reaction most people have
they're highly intelligent and obviously
their beauty and grace just helps us
form another connection to them I've
heard people say there isn't much
mystery left in nature but eagle rays
remind me that there are still animals
we know hardly anything about answering
the basic questions can help us better
understand them and then turn protect
whole ecosystems watching this discovery
firsthand was a true privilege it makes
me wonder what other hidden secrets must
be waiting out there
you